NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseware continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
The aim of our lecture today is
to present what is perhaps
the singly most powerful
recipe for evaluating
indefinite or, for that matter,
definite integrals.
It's called integration by
parts, and therefore, today's
lecture is called 'Integration
by Parts'.
And what I want to emphasize is
essentially that this is a
technique which shows us how to
find indefinite integrals,
but then in theory, it
changes nothing over
what we've had before.
This is essentially, as we've
mentioned, a recipe for being
able to simplify or reduce
indefinite integrals to things
that we can handle.
Well, it centers around
the rule for
differentiating a product.
And to show you what I mean by
that, let's just barge right
into this thing.
In differential notation, we
call the 'u' and 'v' our
differentiable functions
of 'x'.
The differential of 'uv' is 'u'
times the differential of
'v', plus 'v' times the
differential of 'u'.
And solving for 'udv', just
transposing, we have that
'udv' is the differential of
'u' times 'v' minus 'vdu'.
Now, what we do is
we integrate both
sides of this equality.
On the left-hand side,
we have interval udv.
On the right-hand side, recall
that the integral of the
derivative just gives us back
the original function.
In other words, if we integrate
the differential of
'uv' up to an arbitrary
constant, we get
back 'u' times 'v'.
The integral of 'vdu' we'll just
denote by integral 'vdu'.
And observe that there's really
an arbitrary constant
coming from this term, an
arbitrary constant coming from
this term, an arbitrary
constant
coming from this term.
But since the sum and difference
of arbitrary
constants is still an arbitrary
constant, we can
neglected all the constants
here, and just lump them
together, and at the
end write plus 'c'.
Or we can leave the 'c' off,
making it implied that the
arbitrary constant is contained
in the symbol
integral 'vdu'.
All right, now we've done
this, but a much more
important question would be--
or exclamation, for that
matter-- would be so what?
See, who cares whether this
happens to be true or not?
The answer is we care.
That's why we're making
up a lecture on it.
And the reason that
we care is this.
That frequently, for a given 'u'
and 'v', 'udv' may have a
completely different nature
about it than does 'vdu'
insofar as being able to
find the integral.
Now again, the best way to show
what we mean by this is
to choose a particular
example.
Let me start, just arbitrarily
here, picking a couple of
simple functions for us to
differentiate or to integrate.
Let's pick 'u' to equal 'x'
and 'v' to equal 'sine x'.
Now, it's simple to see from
this example that in this
case, if 'u' equals 'x' and 'v'
is 'sine x', then 'dv' is
''cosine x' dx'.
In fact, let's write that down
so we can see it here.
Notice that in this particular
case, integral 'udv' is
integral of 'x 'cosine
x' dx'--
'udv'.
On the other hand,
what is 'vdu'?
'v' is 'sine x'.
Then since 'u' equals
'x', 'du' is 'dx'.
Therefore, 'vdu' is just
integral ''sine x' dx'.
Now, look at these
two integrals.
This one we can integrate
just by looking at it.
It's minus 'cosine x'.
This one, well, offhand, we
don't know a function whose
derivative with respect to
'x' is 'x 'cosine x''.
However, by this recipe, we now
have a way of showing how
to 'udv' once we know
integral 'vdu'.
In other words, in this
particular problem, letting
'u' equal 'x' and 'dv' being
''cosine x' dx', we can
proceed as follows.
Namely, by this recipe,
we get what?
Integral 'x 'cosine x' dx' is
equal to-- this is 'udv'
equals 'u' times 'v'.
Recall that 'u' was 'x', 'v' is
'sine x', so 'u' times 'v'
is 'x sine x', minus
integral 'vdu'.
But 'v' is 'sine x', 'du' is
'dx', so we wind up with this.
But now we know that the
integral of 'sine x' with
respect to 'x' is minus
the 'cosine x'.
The minus and the minus cancel
to give me a plus.
And I wind up with that the
integral of 'x 'cosine x' dx'
is 'x sine x' plus 'cosine
x' plus an
arbitrary constant, OK.
That's all integration
by parts really is.
All we do here is we evaluate
one integral by knowing
another integral.
And by the way, what I meant
here when I said that one did
not have to change any of the
theory, what does the integral
mean here anyway?
What we mean by this is what?
Find all functions whose
derivative with respect to 'x'
is 'x cosine x'.
Now, what integration by parts
did for us was it showed us
how to get this result.
But if we didn't know how to get
this result, observe that
we check the answer the
same way as always.
Namely, one thing that hopefully
we can do is
differentiate this thing.
And if we differentiate
it, let's see.
This is a product.
It's the first factor times the
derivative of the second.
That's 'x cosine x'.
Plus the second factor times the
derivative of the first.
That's just 'sine x'.
The derivative of 'cosine
x' is minus 'sine x'.
The derivative of
a constant is 0.
And if we now sum up the pieces
that we have here, we
wind up with 'x cosine x'.
Exactly what we were supposed
to get, OK?
Now, you see again, nothing
has happened in theory.
All we have now is a technique
that allows us to explicitly
solve certain problems that
we couldn't have solved
otherwise, even though we
could've stated them before.
For example, let's go back to
a problem that technically
speaking we could have presented
before we got to
this unit of our material.
Let's support that the region
'R' is the region bounded
above by 'y' equals 'cosine
x', below by the x-axis
between the y-axis at
'x' equals pi/2.
What we want to do is take this
region 'R' and revolve it
about the y-axis.
And what we'd like to find is
what volume is generated when
the region 'R' is revolved
about the y-axis.
Now, when we talked about
volumes and cylindrical
shells, we already
had the recipe.
Recall that to rotate this
about the y-axis, just to
refresh memories here, if we
call this 'x' and we call this
'y', the element of
volume was what?
Well, you swung out a
circumference '2 pi x' times
height 'y' times
thickness 'dx'.
In other words, that the volume
when this was rotated
about the y-axis was just 2 pi
integral 'x 'cosine x' dx' as
'x' goes from 0 to pi/2.
You see, I rigged this
particular problem so we
wouldn't have to waste the fact
that we've already found
out what the indefinite
integral of 'x
'cosine x' dx' is.
In other words, we get down
to this step here.
Now, by the first fundamental
theorem of integral calculus,
we know that whatever this
integral is, it's also equal
to 'G of pi/2' minus 'G of 0',
where 'G' is any function of
'x' whose derivative with
respect to 'x' is the
integrand here, which
is 'x cosine x'.
Now, you see, this part, or up
to here, we could have got
this result without
today's lecture.
The only thing that we learned
to do today that we couldn't
do before was the idea of how
we find a function whose
derivative is 'x cosine x'.
In fact, what we
found was what?
A function whose derivative is
'x cosine x' is just 'x sine
x' plus 'cosine x'.
So by the first fundamental
theorem, the answer to our
volume problem is that it's 2 pi
times the quantity 'x sine
x' plus 'cosine x' evaluated
between 0 and pi/2.
Putting in 'x' equals pi/2,
this term is pi/2.
This term is 0.
Putting in the lower limit when
'x' is 0, this term is 0.
This term is 1.
We subtract the lower limit.
That gives us a minus 1.
And therefore, the volume that
we get is simply 2 pi times
pi/2 minus 1.
Again, notice then, that the
only new thing that we had to
do here was devise a way for
finding a function whose
derivative with respect to
'x' was 'x cosine x'.
By the way, I think you'll
observe over here that I
started in kind of a rigged
fashion, namely, I started
with a specific 'u' and 'v'.
It might be interesting to see
how would one tackle this
problem if one had just been
given the 'x 'cosine x' dx'
and had to work from there.
In other words, instead of
working backwards now, let's
present the problem as it
would come up in a real
problem, namely, all of a
sudden, we find that we have
to integrate 'x cosine x'.
And the idea go something
like this.
You see, we say lookit.
If this 'x' weren't in
here, this would be
pretty easy to handle.
So why don't we do this?
Why don't we call this piece
here 'u' and call
this piece here 'dv'.
Then, you see, 'du' would
just be 'dx'.
'v' would just be 'sine x'.
In other words, the differential
of 'sine x' is
'cosine x dx'.
See, if 'u' is 'x',
'du' is 'dx'.
If 'dv' is 'cosine x dx', 'v'
is equal to 'sine x'.
I suppose, technically speaking
here, I should put in
plus a constant, but I'll show
later why we can disregard
this constant.
Roughly speaking, it just hinges
on the fact that we
want only one solution.
But we'll talk about
that later.
For the time being, I'll just
leave out the fact that
there's a whole family
of functions.
All I want is one function
whose differential
is 'cosine x dx'.
At any rate, I now apply my
recipe, namely, integral 'udv'
is equal to 'u' times 'v'--
that's 'x sine x'--
minus integral 'v', which
is 'sine x', times 'du',
which is just 'dx'.
In other words, integral 'x
'cosine x' dx' is just 'x sine
x' minus 'sine x dx'.
But I know how to integrate
'sine x'.
It's just minus 'cosine x'.
Therefore, replacing integral
'sine x dx' by minus 'cosine
x' plus a constant.
The minus cancels here.
I wind up with the same result
as before, only now hopefully
in terms of a smooth flow
not that didn't
presuppose the answer.
Namely, this integral
is 'x sine x' plus
'cosine x' plus a constant.
And by the way, I should
mention here that this
technique does require a certain
amount of ingenuity.
In other words, in a given
problem, where you're not told
what to call 'u' and what to
call 'v', where you have the
choice of picking what's going
to be 'u' and what's going to
be 'dv', there is a certain
element of insight that one
needs to guess wisely.
In this particular problem,
it's kind of obvious
which way to guess.
But let me, just to give you the
experience, show you what
happens when you guess
incorrectly.
For example, given the same
problem, why couldn't I have
said gee, I think I'll let
'cosine x' be 'u', and what's
left over, namely, 'xdx'.
That will be 'dv'.
Now, notice that mathematically,
no harm is
done this way.
Namely, if 'u' is 'cosine x',
'du' is minus 'sine x dx'.
If 'dv' is 'xdx', 'v'
is 1/2 'x squared'.
And now, applying the recipe,
integral 'udv' is what?
It's 'uv'.
That's 1/2 'x squared' times
'cosine x' minus
the integral 'vdu'.
But 'vdu' is already minus 1/2
'x squared' 'sine x dx', so
minus that is plus
1/2 integral ''x
squared' 'sine x' dx'.
And I wind up with the result
that the integral 'x 'cosine
x' dx' is 1/2 'x squared'
'cosine x' plus 1/2 integral
''x squared' 'sine x' dx'.
And there is absolutely nothing
at all wrong with
this, except that the chances
are if I didn't know how to
find the function whose
derivative was 'x cosine x',
what is the likelihood that
I know a function whose
derivative is ''x squared'
'sine x' dx'?
In other words, here's a case
where replacing 'udv' by 'vdu'
gave me an equivalent integral
to evaluate which was more
cumbersome than the first.
In fact, somehow or other, it
would seem that by multiplying
through here by 2 and solving
for ''x squared' 'sine x' dx',
that it would seem that somehow
or other this would be
a way of simplifying
the integral ''x
squared' 'sine x' dx'.
In other words, if you had
started with this, I think
you'd accept the fact, well,
this still isn't as nice as
I'd like it, but it does seem
less complicated than this.
You see, at least the power of
'x' is only to the first power
here, whereas here it's
the second power.
In fact, this leads
to a technique
called a reduction formula.
Again, using hindsight rather
than foresight, having
motivated the integral ''x
squared' 'sine x' dx', let's
see how I could have solved this
particular problem if I
didn't know what the answer was
going to be in advance.
You see, I say to myself, you
know, this x squared here is
bothering me.
If that 'x squared' weren't
here, this would be pretty
easy to handle.
Well, the best way to knock the
'x squared' down is to let
'u' equal 'x squared',
in which case,
'du' will be '2xdx'.
In other words, your second
power will now be replaced by
a first power.
It's not perfect, but at least
there's hope here.
At any rate, what I'm saying is
motivated into calling 'u'
'x squared' and therefore
letting 'dv' be the rest of
this integrand, which is 'sine
x dx', we wind up with the
fact that 'du' is '2xdx' and
'v' is minus 'cosine x'.
Well, you see now, remembering
that 'u' is 'x squared', 'dv'
is 'sine x dx', the recipe tells
us that integral 'udv'
is 'u' times 'v'.
That's minus 'x cosine x'
minus integral 'vdu'.
But integral 'dvu' is integral
twice 'x 'cosine x' dx' with a
minus sign.
The minus sign in the recipe
makes it plus.
And we therefore wind up with
that integral ''x squared'
'sine x' dx' is equal to minus
''x squared' 'cosine x'' plus
twice integral 'x
'cosine x' dx'.
By the way, just to refresh your
memories on this, if we
come back and compare this with
what we had over here,
it's exactly the same thing.
The only difference now
is that we arrived
at this thing directly.
Now you see the point is, having
reduced this to this, I
can now use integration by parts
again to simplify this.
In other words, what I would do
next is let 'u' equal 'x'
and 'dv' be 'cosine x dx'.
But let's face it, I've already
done this problem.
Time is getting short.
Why do it again?
The point is that integral 'x
cosine x' using integration by
parts again is going to come
out to be 'x sine x' plus
'cosine x' plus 'c' because
that's what we got before when
we used integration by
parts to do this.
At any rate, what I would now
do is replace integral 'x
cosine x' in here by this, OK?
And if I do that, I have what?
Integral ''x squared' 'sine
x' dx' is equal to what?
Minus ''x squared' 'cosine x''
plus twice times this, which
is twice this.
That's what?
2 'x sine x' plus 2 'cosine
x' plus a constant.
And by the way, again notice,
if I wanted to check whether
this was right, the one thing I
can do if somebody gives me
this is what?
I can differentiate it
with respect to 'x'.
When I differentiate it with
respect to 'x', if I get ''x
squared' 'sine x'' as my result,
this is correct.
Otherwise, I've made
a mistake.
But the idea is keep in mind
that these can always be
checked because they're
inverse derivatives.
They can always be checked by
actual differentiation.
And again, notice the beauty
of this technique.
If somebody said construct the
function whose derivative with
respect to 'x' is ''x squared'
'sine x'', notice how
difficult it would be to try to
piece this thing together.
See, notice the difference
between being able to check
that this is a right answer and
how one would find this.
This is the technique of a power
of integration by parts.
In fact, in making up exam
questions, this is exactly how
professor sometimes do this.
That what you start with is you
start with this, then give
a person this problem and tell
them to differentiate this.
And that whole mess simply
comes out to be ''x
squared' 'sine x''.
And that's why a lot of times
when you have a messy problem
to differentiate and you look
at the answer in the back of
the book, you become amazed to
see that the thing really
simplified.
Again, notice the idea.
The integrand here is
relatively simple.
What we have to differentiate to
get that relatively simple
integrand is not quite
so simple.
But enough about that.
Let me just go on with
a few more examples.
See, I have plenty of examples
in the exercises to keep you
busy and to give you
drill on this.
All I'm trying to do now is to
motivate places where one
would want to use integration
by parts.
Well, let me show you one
place it might be used.
One place that it's always worth
trying is when you look
at the integrand, haven't the
vaguest notion as to how to
integrate it, but you are able
to differentiate it.
You see, you've got
nothing to lose.
The worst that will happen is
that the resulting integral
vdu will be no easier to handle
than the original udv,
but at least there's a chance
that something will work.
But let me give you
a for instance.
I see I've written this
rather badly.
This is not 'Stan'.
This is the integral of inverse
'tangent x dx', OK?
Integral inverse
'tangent x dx'.
What function has its derivative
equal to inverse
'tangent x'?
Well, you see, the thing I do
know hopefully is what the
derivative of inverse
'tangent x' is.
The derivative of inverse
'tangent x' with respect to
'x' is '1 over '1 plus
x squared''.
And by the way, if you don't
know this, there's no hope of
even beginning the integration
by parts. in other words, we
have to assume that we
can do something in a
problem like this.
At any rate, knowing this,
what do I do next?
I say, well, since I know how
to differentiate the inverse
tangent, that's a very natural
thing to call 'u' because I
can certainly find 'du'.
Moreover, the nice thing is that
calling 'dv' 'dx', if I
can integrate anything,
it's certainly 'dx'.
Namely, what I'm saying is if
'u' equals inverse 'tan x' and
'dv' is 'dx', then 'du' is 'dx'
over '1 plus x squared',
and 'v' is just equal to 'x'.
Now, therefore, integral inverse
'tan x dx', in other
words, integral 'udv',
is just what?
It's still just 'u' times 'v'.
That's 'x' times inverse
'tan x' minus 'vdu'.
That's minus integral
'x' times 'dx'
over '1 plus x squared'.
Now, look what happens
in this case.
Obviously, with time being short
and having other places
to show you my failures, namely
in the exercises, I
picked one that worked nicely.
Here's the case, you see, that
the integral inverse 'tan x
dx', by using parts, becomes
replaced by integral 'xdx'
over '1 plus x squared'.
This is one I can handle
from before.
This is one where the
substitution 'u' equals '1
plus x squared' works
very nicely for me.
Or if you're getting glib with
these things, just observe
that this integrand
is 1/2 natural
log '1 plus x squared'.
Because how would you
differentiate natural log '1
plus x squared'?
It would just be what? '1 over
'1 plus x squared'' times the
derivative of this,
which is '2x'.
The 2 and the 1/2 would cancel,
and we just have left
'x over '1 plus x squared''.
In other words, again, notice
that the answer here is what?
This is the function that one
would have to differentiate
with respect to 'x' to wind
up with inverse 'tan x'.
I'll show you another example
in a few minutes.
What I did just remember is that
I mentioned why we can
drop the arbitrary constant.
Let me just take a minute here
and show how this problem
should have really
been worked.
If we wanted to be precise here,
we'd say OK, 'u' equals
inverse 'tan x'.
Therefore, 'du' is 'dx over
'1 plus x squared''.
That part's fine.
Then we say, OK, 'dv' is 'dx'.
Now, if 'dv' is 'dx',
what must 'v' be?
Well, 'v' could be 'x', but it
must be something of the form
'x' plus some constant,
which I'll call 'c1'.
Could I have chosen 'v'
to be 'x plus c1'?
Why not?
In fact, what would have
happened if I did that?
Notice that what would have
happened in this case is that
'u' times 'v' now would simply
have been 'x plus c1' times
inverse 'tan x', whereas
integral 'vdu', instead of
being 'xdx' over '1 plus x
squared' would have been ''x
plus c1' dx' over '1
plus x squared'.
In other words, leaving the
constant in, I would get this.
And now all I want you to see
here, and I've done this just
for this particular example,
and in the exercises we'll
work it out in general.
The whole idea is this.
This, of course, can be written
as two terms, one of
which is 'x inverse tan x', and
the other of which is 'c1
inverse tan x'.
This also can be written
as two integrals.
Namely, with the minus sign
kept aside here, this is
integral of 'xdx' over '1 plus
x squared' and plus integral
'c1 dx' over '1 plus x squared',
the minus making
this minus.
But we know that the integral
'dx' over '1 plus x squared'
is inverse 'tan x'.
In other words, if we now
separate these into
pieces, we have what?
'x inverse tan x' minus
integral 'xdx'
over '1 plus x squared'.
And notice that the 'c1' term
drops out because we have 'c1
inverse tan x' occurring
twice.
It's this term here,
and it's also
this part of our integral.
And see, with the minus sign
here, they just cancel out.
And that's why we really don't
have to keep the arbitrary
constant in there, but if
we wish to, we may.
At any rate, let me summarize
with just one more problem to
make sure that we have the
technique down fairly pat.
Let's suppose we were given
integral 'log x dx'.
What we certainly do know I hope
by this time is that the
derivative of 'log x' with
respect to 'x' is '1/x'.
Since I can differentiate 'log
x', it becomes very meaningful
to try letting 'u'
equal 'log x'.
If I do this, 'u' is 'log x'.
'dv' is 'dx'.
'du' then becomes ''1 over
x' dx', and 'v' is 'x'.
And now I put in plus 'c' in
parentheses here to indicate
that if you wanted to
use it, you could.
At any rate, what happens now?
Integral udv, integral 'log x
dx' in this case is 'u' times
'v', which is 'x log x',
minus integral 'vdu'.
Well, you see the 'x' times
the '1/x' is just 1.
Therefore, 'vdu' is just
'dx', so minus that
is just minus 'dx'.
In other words, minus the
integral 'vdu' is just minus
integral 'dx'.
And now, you see I have
what? 'x log x'.
And this is very easy
to integrate.
It just happens to be minus
'x', then I tack on the
arbitrary constant.
Again, to check whether this
was the right answer, all I
have to do is differentiate 'x
log x' minus 'x' with respect
to 'x' and see if I get 'log
x', and I will, OK?
Now, how would I use a problem
like this, say,
in a practical situation?
Well, for example, suppose I
wanted to find the area of the
region 'R' where 'R' was the
region bounded above by the
curve 'y' equals 'natural log
x', below by the x-axis, on
the left by 'x' equals 1, and
on the right by 'x' equals
'b', where 'b' can be any number
you want right now as
long as it's bigger than
1 in this diagram.
Notice that the definite
integral says that the area of
the region 'R' is the definite
integral from 1
to 'b', 'log x dx'.
And the first fundamental
theorem of
calculus says lookit.
If you happen to know a function
whose derivative with
respect to 'x' is 'log
x', you can evaluate
this thing very quickly.
Namely, it's just 'G of b' minus
'G of 1' where 'G prime
of x' is 'log x'.
Well, you see, we do know a
function now whose derivative
with respect to 'x' is
'log x', namely, 'x
log x' minus 'x'.
Consequently, to solve this
problem, all I have to do is
evaluate this between the limits
of 1 and 'b', which I
won't bother doing
right now, OK?
Now, here's the idea.
What we've really learned here
is one more powerful technique
for evaluating integrals.
How we arrive at integrals
in no way changes in this
particular lecture.
All we have now is what?
A new technique whereby we
evaluate udv by being able to
evaluate equivalently vdu.
At any rate, that finishes up
what we had in mind for today,
and so until next
time, goodbye.
NARRATOR: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.